[Musik]
und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend der Krieg war nie
vorbei aber es gab immerhin eine Woche
Feuerpause jetzt ist die vorbei und der
Krieg wieder voll da mehr als 200 Ziele
hat Israels Armee in den vergangenen
Stunden im Norden und auch im Süden des
abgeriegelten Gazastreifens angegriffen
dort wohin hunderttausende Menschen
geflohen sind in der Hoffnung wenigstens
ein bisschen sicherer zu se sein die
zahlreichen Todesopfer unter der
Zivilbevölkerung und die Vertreibung in
einem Ausmaß wie man sie im Norden
gesehen habe dürfe sich im Süden nicht
wiederholen hatte der US Außenminister
gemahnt an die Adresse Israels luten
Linus raketenalarm der Krieg ist zurück
die Hamas beschießt wieder Israel das
reagiert mit aller Härte schickt Panzer
Kampfflugzeuge und
Bomben hat die Hamas entschieden die
Feuerpause zu beenden sie ist nicht
bereit weitere entführte Frauen und
Kinder freizulassen und sie greift mit
Raketen an dieamas wird nun die Mutter
aller Schläge zu spüren
bekommen zeitgleich veröffentlicht
Israels Armee diese Karte sie teilt den
Gazastreifen in Hunderte Sektoren ein
auf Arabisch fordert ein Sprecher die
Bewohner auf sich die Nummer ihres
Sektors zu merken falls dieser evakuiert
werden müsse
viele Bomben trafen heute Orte wie
chanunis wohin bereits hundertausende
aus nordgasa geflüchtet sind nun fordern
israelische Flugblätter die Menschen auf
noch weiter in den Süden nach Raffa zu
gehen wir waren zu Hause und hörten
gerade Nachrichten als die Bomben fielen
und unser Haus
zerstörten wir sind müde ständig werden
wir bombardiert wie sollen wir es in
dieser gefährlichen Lage schaffen bis
nach Raffa zu
kommen singen sich Mut zu auf dem Platz
der Geiseln in Tel Aviv omris Bruder ist
unter den entführten lange war er für
verhandeln die Rückkehr zum Krieg jetzt
trägt er
mit ich vertraue meiner Regierung sie
wird das beste tun und danach zu
Verhandlungen über Freilassungen
zurückkehren als vorerst letzte
chamasgeiseln haben acht Frauen und
Teenager es vergangene Nacht
rausgeschafft aus dem Gazastreifen
136 sollen noch Gefangene der
Terroristen sein
unabhängig vom aktuellen Kriegsgeschehen
sorgt ein Bericht der New York Times für
Aufsehen danach hatte Israel bereits
mehr als ein Jahr vor dem verheerenden
Terrorangriff der Hamas vom 7 Oktober
Informationen über entsprechende Pläne
der Terroristen luten guten Abend nach
Tel Aviv um was für ein Dokument dass
die Zeitung da offenbar hat geht es
denn es geht um ein Dokument das präzise
vorzeichnet wie der Angriff dann
tatsächlich am 7 Oktober stattgefunden
hat 40 Seiten dick wird dort beschrieben
wie die Hamas es geschafft hat
tatsächlich die gesamten
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen Israels
auszuschalten und diesen Angriff zu
organisieren ein ein Dokument dass der
New York Times vorliegt und von dem sie
sagt dass es die Regierung und die
Behörden Israels schon seit über einem
Jahr in Hände halten und es geht
zweitens um einen Bericht einer
geheimdienstexpertin Israels die drei
Monate vor dem Angriff beobachtet hat
wie die Hamas eine Übung abhielt die
genau das sozusagen nachspielte und
trainierte was in diesem äh in diesem
Bericht und in diesem Plan sozusagen
vorgezeichnet war ähm beides sind sehr
sehr erstaunliche Enthüllungen die heute
in der politischen Diskussion in Israel
aber tatsächlich nur in der
Berichterstattung der Medien eine Rolle
spielen die Frage nach politischen
Konsequenzen die wird hier im Moment
nicht gestellt man vereint sich hinter
dem Ministerpräsident und der Regierung
bis dieser Krieg vorbei ist und erst
danach wird es dann an die politische
Abrechnung gehen und dann geht es wohl
auch um das politische Überleben von
Ministerpräsident netanaho sagt luten
leinus live in Tel Aviv luten herzlichen
Dank
dafür unser Planet hat eine schwere
Krankheit sagt der UNO Generalsekretär
heute die Diagnose stimmt was zu tun ist
sagt der Mann auch bzw wer jetzt
gefordert wäre es ist eine Krankheit die
nur sie die Führer der Welt heilen
können ruft Antonio guteres dutzenden
Staats- und Regierungschefs zu in Dubai
auf der Weltklimakonferenz ist heute der
Tag der sogenannten Highlevel Meetings
auch für den Bundeskanzler Andrea
Stam kein roter ein grauer Teppich für
den Bundeskanzler fast schon symbolisch
seine Regierung ist die Finanzierung der
Klimapolitik um die Ohren geflogen dem
selbsternannten klimakanzler kein
leichter Gang denn es haakt nicht nur in
Deutschland ich bin überzeugt dass sich
hier auch herausstellen wird dass
natürlich mehr Tempo notwendig ist und
wenn man weiß wie nah die Aufgaben sind
die wir erreicht haben müssen dann ist
es eben auch wichtig dass man sich
gemeinsam unterhakt einhaken etwa beim
klimaclub einem Herzensprojekt von
Scholz das nun durchstarten soll
gemeinsam mit bislang 36 Ländern will
man Industriezweige wie die
energieintensive Stahl und
Zementproduktion grün machen riesige
Mengen Treibhausgase einsparen und
gleichzeitig Arbeitsplätze sichern
grundsätzlich ist es gut dass sich eine
kleine Gruppe von Ländern zusammentut
und einen Themenbereich vorantreibt das
ist sehr wichtig und nötig aber es kommt
sehr auf die Umsetzung drauf an ob das
tatsächlich erfolgreich ist oder wie
viele andere Initiativen vorher im Sande
verläuft eine frage halt nach kann
Deutschland in seiner aktuellen
Verfassung noch ein Vorreiter beim
internationalen Klimaschutz sein es wäre
nötig die 140 Staats und Regierungschefs
scheint es beweinen am Mittag irgendwie
das eigene Scheitern dass sie bislang
nicht genug getan haben für das große
Ziel für dass die Weltklimakonferenz
überhaupt zusammenkommt Wege finden um
die Erderwärmung auf 1,5° zu
begrenzen der Planet ist müde von
Klimaabkommen die das Papier nicht wert
sind von CO2 einsparzielen die nicht
eingehalten werden oder versprochenen h
für die ärmsten Länder die niemals
kommen dabei lege es in der Hand der
statenlenker sie könnten in Dubai den
schnellen Ausstieg aus der fossilen
Energiewirtschaft beschließen das
heißeste Eisen in der ölmetropole doch
das Ende von Kohle Öl und Gas scheint in
weiter Ferne so Experten aber aufgeben
auch keine Lösung frankreichs
Staatspräsident bringt es unfreiwillig
auf den Punkt die Welt kennt eigentlich
den Weg aber bei der Umsetzung sitzt und
passt es immer noch nicht
richtig vielleicht auch ein bisschen
überladen der Wagen so was heute noch
wichtig ist jetzt im Überblick mit dir
Hanna der Bundestag hat heute in erster
Lesung über den Nachtragshaushalt 2023
debattiert für den in diesem Jahr erneut
die Schuldenbremse ausgesetzt werden
soll der AFD Haushaltspolitiker böinger
bezeichnete die dazu nötige rückwirkende
Erklärung einer Notsituation als
dreisten Trick der Haushalt bleibe
verfassungswidrig unionsfraktionsvizze
Middelberg forderte die Ampel zum Sparen
auf und nannte das Bürgergeld für den
Haushalt 2024 kündigte Finanzminister
Lindner an nicht mehr notwendige
Ausgaben zu
depriorisieren nach seinem Willen soll
die Schuldenbremse dann wieder
gelten russland will seine Armee weiter
vergrößern und die Zahl der bewaffneten
Kräfte um 170.000 vertragssoldaten und
werrdienstleistende erhöhen das sind
knapp 15%. dazu hat der russische
Präsident Putin heute ein entsprechendes
Dekret unterzeichnet die russischen
Streitkräfte wachsen damit auf insgesamt
1,32 Millionen Mann die letzte
Vergrößerung der Armee hatte Putin erst
im vergangenen Sommer
angeordnet um Berufe in der Altenpflege
attraktiver zu machen und so dem
bestehenden Personalmangel
entgegenzuwiken steigt ab heute der
Mindestlohn für rund 1,3 Millionen
Beschäftigte in diesem Bereich
Pflegehilfskräfte bekommen nun
14,15 € pro Stunde qualifizierte
Pflegehilfskräfte 15,25 € und
Pflegefachkräfte 18,25 € eine weitere
Anhebung ist für den 1 Mai
geplant seit dem heutigen Tag gilt auf
Autobahnen und Bundesstraßen in
Deutschland eine deutlich höhere Maut
für schwere Lkw pro Ausgestoßener Tonne
CO2 kommt ein Aufschlag von 200 € dazu
der Bund erwartet durch die neue Abgabe
mehrinnahmen in Milliardenhöhe die unter
anderem in den Schienenbau fließen
sollen zudem soll der CO2 Aufschlag
Anreiz geben mehr saubere Antriebe auf
die Straße zu bringen Logistik
Unternehmen kritisieren den Schritt und
warnen vor steigenden Preisen für die
Verbraucher problematische Wölfe sollen
in Zukunft deutlich schneller
abgeschossen werden können darauf haben
sich die Umweltminister von Bund und
Ländern bei Treffen in Münster geeinigt
überwindet ein Wolf Schutzzäune und
reißt Nutztiere darf er künftig ohne
vorherige DNA Analyse abgeschossen
werden dies gilt für 21 Tage aber nur in
bestimmten Regionen mit vielen
wolfsrissen die die Bundesländer vorher
festlegen
müssen es gibt eine aktuelle
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor starkem Schneefall im
Süden von Bayern und so sind die
Aussichten morgen vom Alpenrand bis bis
zur Lause teils kräftige Schneefälle
sonst freundlicher und nur einzelne
Schneeschauer -5 bis + 2° am Sonntag nur
noch wenig Schnee und häufiger Sonne bei
-5 bis + 3° in der neuen Woche von
Westen her zunächst Schnee später
Glatteisregen und wieder
milder und so viel von uns hier für den
Moment gegen 030 Uhr gibt's dann unser
heute journal Update mit Laura barnik
ein angenehmen Abend und viel Spaß beim
Fußball tschüss
[Musik]